this is uh
ee 380 winter 2022
and uh the
speaker today is
david ankle wallace
and david is um
a long-standing silicon valley
entrepreneur
and he is uh
dead
dead set
to make the world safer by producing
more co2
that's right
in any case um
uh
the the chair is yours
and uh we'll um
interrupt from questions
perhaps over time hi i'm david henkel
wallace what i'm going to talk to you
today
is about climate restoration that is
repairing the climate to make it more
commodious to to human life
and why we should be doing that i'm
going to talk about uh
some projects in that regard and
specifically about uh my work
uh and on my team i'm working with work
on removing methane
which is one of the worst greenhouse
gases even worse than co2
and trying to cut the temperature by
half a degree
so
restoration climate restoration is an
unusual term
uh to most people uh i've talked to a
lot of people about i don't realize that
it's even possible to fix things
um because
mostly when you read the news people
talk about uh privation right you must
eliminate emissions and i i think that's
a good thing but that seems to be pretty
much
how people think you can uh
you can improve the climate somehow
you're gonna
generate less co2 emit less co2
uh abatement means instead of
reducing emissions by not driving your
car as much uh but it means uh you know
cutting off
emission sources
like oil rigs and things like that and
then the other thing which is completed
with that is we should switch to cleaner
energy sources and cleaner
itself is it's like the food plate in
the from the department of agriculture
uh it's
it's cleaner by a definition that's not
normally uh
used by uh
by normal human beings for example uh
emitting methane is conceived considered
cleaner than burning coal
over the past two or three years the
federal government in the u.s has
started to recognize
the idea that you might adapt to the
climate that is build more
sea walls
rebuild houses that get destroyed right
in the place where they were destroyed
and in general
not do anything about the climate
problem
but what i'm talking about today is why
aren't we cleaning up the mess in the
first place that's certainly what we
would do if we had a big party in our
house
and uh and the police were a mess we
wouldn't just decide to buy fewer
cheetos we might say hey maybe i'll
switch to something different
so that and and we would vacuum up the
house
so we're right i just want to tell a
little bit more we're on an absurd path
right now okay the un's position
is that we is is to reduce the rate
at which we cause damage
so basically they're actually just
decreasing the second derivative
of the problem uh i have a friend who
calls this a suicide pact
and uh it really is because all we're
doing is we're literally kicking the
the problem down the road but with no
plans
to actually even address it
okay
and so uh i have this graph here
and it shows that uh i think people
don't realize
that
they're gonna they're we're gonna
increase the amount of co2 by
over 50
if the u.n is successful which to date
of course
they have not been
our goal
if you look at this graph is to take
that blue that green follow the path of
the green line
and bring the level of co2 down
uh below the uh below the level that
or around around where it was
um
well in 1775 because i'll tell you
so
the un plan
is to tolerate co2 levels up at 450
parts per million
and the historic levels through
through human existence have
been about 280.
right so uh
the un is basically willing to tolerate
a temperature and co2 level higher than
humans have ever survived before i have
some more graphs about that
so our goal is to build a planet have a
habitable
habitable to humans
right and that's different from saying
we're going to
go back to the exactly the way it was i
mean this hysteresis loops here right
it's too late but
with uh already um
you know mass extinctions
um and changes to the environment we're
not going to go back where we were but
we can go back to a place
that is good for is good for huma we can
bring the climate to a place that's good
for humans because after all the planet
doesn't care anyway the whole purpose of
this project is to make it make is to
make is to terraform the earth and which
is what we've been doing for the past
few thousand years to make it
comfortable for human beings
well i'll keep going anyway
sorry you can't see my graph i have a
graph
uh it's a pretty scary looking graph
because this one shows carbon dioxide
concentrations over the holocene and
you'll see from over the last 100 000
years
the
the curve is basically flat right a
little bit of noise the curve is
basically flat and in 1775
suddenly
the thing the the thing that the curve
it becomes almost vertical
so we're not going to go back to the
status quo aren't they but it turns out
people don't really want to okay
people have adapted the climate they've
destroyed the forests because they've
turned them into economic value
removed the dangerous animals and we now
have a curated environment and uh
for the net you know for the foreseeable
future certainly my lifetime we will
continue to have a curated environment
um as i said there's too many hysteresis
loops and you just can't go back once
you cut a forest down for for
firewood
it doesn't grow back up the same way
because you've destroyed all of the
undergrowth
um
once you just kill once you've done that
you've killed off a lot of the animals
they don't come back
um
the other but there's also scarier more
short-term problems that we're worried
about um
i think uh the new in the news recently
there's been some discussion about the
um
the melting of the russian tundra
and frozen in that tundra is decomposing
matter from the last ice age
and uh and as it warms up there's that's
causing bursts of methane to be released
into the atmosphere but what i haven't
seen in the popular press is the fact
that also there was partially decomposed
material that as the heat has as it's
defrosted has now def started
decomposing at an accelerating rate just
emitting uh emitting methane at its uh
uh on its own not fossilized anything
and that methane um
in 2020 methane
levels rose twice as high as had been
previously recorded
okay and nobody knows why
so the the current theory is the melting
of the tundra and that tundra is on fire
actually as we speak
um
and the russian firemen are having
trouble putting it out
okay
so
our target is to get the climate back
because you can't see my graphs my our
target is to get the climate back to uh
human to to something commodities to
humans to 1775 levels um within within
the next three decades
okay by 2050 and we think it's possible
um
the reason i mentioned 1775 by the way
because of our audience here is that's
the year james watt got his patents
and set us off on this deadly path
okay so
i've been a little cynical about the un
um
and i don't mean to be because they're
actually reacting to what people what
people want which is
they want to do as little as possible
um
you know they're busy people are busy
changing the environment all the time by
you know driving their car to the
grocery store a mile to the grocery
store to pick up one loaf of bread um
there's a
complex uh bit of geoengineering going
on there and
nobody's gonna stop that humans are
gonna human
so
you know what we need is uh is to have i
think what what what people do
interestingly react well to is private
sector efforts
to to to work on the environment they're
very excited if there's a direct air
capture co2 machine because it feels
like uh someone's someone else is doing
the work and i don't have to do the work
and uh and we've adopted that strategy
um and there are other people that i'm
going to talk about who have adopted
that approach
which is to
find ways to profitably
or at least outside government and ngo
activity
processes to work on climate climate uh
repair
okay there are already frameworks that
you can fit in
from environmental studies
specially designed experimental regimes
like the london protocol
carbon certification trading
and the usual subsidy tax efforts these
transitional tools are still used at
negligible levels
uh but they have caused a revolution in
energy generation and we are we and some
others are surfing that same process
uh to work on to to actually start
implementing climate restoration
okay
so
there's a psychological factor that
we're finding people are responsive to
um because they're you know
all of us are busy changing the climate
we're just busy we have the sign
backwards
and so our group of blue dot change some
other
groups that i can tell i'm going to talk
about um
are making it easy for people to support
working in the opposite direction
okay now um
i have a bias to techniques okay
so my bias
is that we should use techniques that
use mechanisms that already exist that
is to say to accelerate
natural processes for uh for climate
restoration now
if you could see my screen and i'll try
one more time
okay well there is an ice graph showing
that uh
over the last uh
uh million years we've had 10 ice ages
so there's a pretty good well-known
technique which we are not going to do
which is to detonate a
ton of volcanoes
um
causing an ice age and uh fortunately
nobody knows how to do this um
but one of the interesting things when
you detonate a ton of volcanoes you get
an interesting cycle of process first of
all you get a lot of shade a ton of
particulate matter goes into the upper
atmosphere and sticks around for a year
or two
um but what's interesting about that
material is it's full of iron
uh among you know sulfur dioxides no
oxes all sorts of stuff
and that iron eventually
washes out into the ocean
and
generates it causes it fertilizes the
ocean and causes a lot of algae to be
born and that algae in the short term is
great because it
chews up co2
breathes out oxygen
and changes the temperature
dies and sinks to the bottom of the
ocean the bad news about that is that as
you
heat up the ocean as we do as we're
doing right now
then uh you change the density of the
ocean and a lot of that methane that was
generated at the bottom of the ocean so
the rotting of this algae suddenly
starts to appear
and again up in the arctic you can
actually see bubbling
bottling regions of the ocean but it
gives you an idea of a direction
a direction you can go
so one of the reasons that i'm a fan of
these natural processes is that these
processes are powered through
ultraviolet and ultraviolet is
provided for free
if you look at these direct air capture
machines that people are trying to build
they need a large amount of power and uh
i don't i don't have a graph of the
calculation but uh i actually don't
believe it's thermometrically viable
uh to actually
take tera tons of co2 out of the
atmosphere with the energy capability
capabilities we have today on the other
hand
we've got this great fusion reactor
93 million miles away that's sending
tons of uvr away and those and that uv
is already used
to uh to sequester to to oxidize methane
to break down co2 or sequester co2
through you know
vegetable processes and it's free it's
already there so um i'm a fan of cross
disease like that um
the uv is used to
sequester uh sequester in biocarbon then
like through processes like i talked
about uh either
uh kelp
that like
the ccrc is experimenting with or
some of the processes that we've done on
algaes
also used to break down methane the
process that i'll be talking about later
in this talk
um you can also look at human processes
at mineralization processes uh that have
that have that that are
performed as a side effect of doing
other human action
uh 90 of the
co2 that's been captured
in
until now has been captured in
biological systems and
making limestone which is basically the
dead the the dead shells of sea
creatures
uh with the phytoplankton
uh and so limestone can be you know
limestone's being produced already uh by
some companies in the uk and a company
here in los angeles
who are generating
limestone for and selling it for
building materials the guys in the uk
have a process that actually also
excretes fresh water
uh on the fire on the experiments that
have been done on building algae uh
they've actually been using the algae to
uh fertilize or to feed fish farms so
part of it sinks to the bottom of the
sea and part of it of course turns into
fish which people eat and then they
breathe the co2 out but it's uh it's
still in that a net positive
so the whole point is to get the
temperature back to normal
okay
if we could use these processes which
not our first our first project to get
60 gigatons of co2 out of the atmosphere
a year
um
we could get the climate down by the end
of the century the co2 levels by the end
of the century down to
1775 levels
okay
now
we have to talk about the deadly word
geoengineering
i know there's at least one person on
this on this call who's a big fan
of those processes um but
every time it comes up
we get opposition and the opposition is
very interesting
um
because
basically anything that looks technical
frightens people
and that's one of the nice things about
these natural processes um of course
they are engineered processes we are
i'll show you what we're doing for
methane but we are doing something
deliberate to accelerate a natural
process
but it's interesting to me that
there's a planting a green wall in
africa they're trying to stop the sahara
desert by building a 4 000 mile
wall of trees and it's incomplete but
it's already changing uh drought and
monsoon patterns in it in africa it's
clearly the geo engineering project but
since it's planting trees
it doesn't get people frightened
so although i i feel from a
thermodynamic reason that we should be
using biological processes to
to restore the climate um it turns out
to be
uh
less frightening to quite a few people
if it's if it has the word natural
attached to it
okay the other thing about the processes
i'm talking about which should be
familiar to a lot of the e 380
uh viewers
is that
these are processes that can start small
and can be scaled linearly right you can
stamp out stamp them out
um by just applying money money and
effort uh not unlike
starting out with one microprocessor and
building a larger machine out of a lot
of them um
these processes are easier i i found are
easier for the lay public to understand
than to build one big machine or you
know put us put a uh
an umbrella out in orbit things like
that really frighten people um but uh
because they're just one thing and i
think these are the kinds of things that
they see in the movies
so let me talk a bit
about what we're actually what we're
doing when we're starting with me thing
so the question is why start with
methane okay there's only about
600 megatons of methane in the
atmosphere at the moment uh there's
almost two
thousand parts per billion two parts per
million and here i was talking about co2
where it would have 300 parts per
million would be ideal
and the reason for that is that
methane is about 50 times as force has
of a forcing greenhouse gas as co2 is
okay
so just that
two parts per million of sea of methane
in the atmosphere has raised the
temperature of the earth by half a
degree
so if we can remove all the human
generated methane or more
then
we can buy ourselves
time another 20 years
to continue working on some of the other
problems that need to be solved so
that's why we are starting with methane
it's a smaller
more tractable problem due to an
interesting
chemical
reaction set of chemical reactions that
i'll talk about and it buys us time it's
a retractable size that will buy us time
to do to do more of the work that needs
to be done
now methane is an interesting chemical
because it is given off through
biological processes
like co2 is but they're diffuse
processes too right so
uh i have this chart on the on the on
the right if
if anyone really wants to look at it
it's a bit of an eye chart there i have
a i have a slide with the whole with
just that picture on it but what this
shows is that humans generate about a
third of the methane emissions actually
in 2021 looks like it might have been
half um and it turns out that
oil refining is not a lot of it's a lot
of it's agriculture uh cows burping
not farting like everyone says uh but
burping uh but it's also coming you know
the bulk of the natural new thing is
just coming from swamps and no one's
gonna be able to fit a catalytic
converter to a swamp right so
regardless of of any amount of human
efforts to curb methane production you
know paddy fields uh natural swamps etc
they are just generating tons of methane
each year you know hundreds of hundreds
of tons of methane each year
now methane
itself lasts uh about
a dozen years in the environment and
breaks down naturally um into
into co2 and h2o
and uh either either through hydroxyl
radicals or or chlorine ions
which we're going to use the chlorine
ion path
um so the problem is of course because
humans are pumping it out at a much
greater rate than than naturally
occurring
methane which is
peg
and
happily protects us
under normal conditions is actually now
cooking us
so um
this is the problem we're trying to get
get through i'm gonna because of time
i'm gonna skip forward a little
um
on the bottom of this
i talked about the
fossilized methane
okay but here's the problem again since
1775
that sort of time when we lost our
ecological innocence and started mining
the past
um
methane levels have uh
have have almost doubled in fact they
now they're now very close to doubles
even the same time when co2 of which
there's a lot more has only gone off
fifty percent
and uh so this the most potent
greenhouse gas that's produced in volume
is
also the one that has been growing the
fastest
you know don't forget when we switch
this is what i'm talking about earlier
when i talked about switching to a clean
fuel
natural gas which is basically just
methane uh is considered by the u.n and
by the epa etc to be a clean alternative
and it's true it generates less soot
but uh what they never talk about is the
the soot and sulfur dioxide that's been
put out by our old dirty technology has
actually been cooling the earth by
reflecting sunlight as we've been
cleaning that up we've actually been
heating the earth up faster
by using a much more dangerous fuel
since i don't anticipate that people are
just going to throw away their natural
gas
investments
tomorrow they're going to wait for them
to
to be completely amortized
we need to take action in the open
atmosphere itself
and we're going to do that in the ocean
if you look at the methane uh
you can tell that the northern
hemisphere has a hell of a lot more than
the southern hemisphere and white that's
because there's lots of people
but the earth mixes and you see that the
the northern hemisphere is all about the
same color and the southern hemisphere
is roughly all about the same the same
color
um and the nice thing about uh oceans is
they don't have topographic features
they're the the atmosphere mixes very
well
so um that's where we're gonna that's
where we're gonna do our work
so what we do is we harness the natural
process of methane oxidation that occurs
in the
troposphere in the oceanic troposphere
that is the part that we breathe when
we're sailing on the ocean
um and what happens what's interesting
is about um
about
15 years ago some scientists in europe
in germany
started investigating the behavior of of
surface chemistry in the ocean and they
noticed that the salt spray
in salt pans or just in the waves
you know of course
everybody's in the ocean knows it's full
of chlorine that salt spray actually
degrades about 15 of the
atmospheric methane
now uh it's catalyzed it's catalyzed by
the present naturally occurring anoxes
and other pollutants
um but what's very interesting about
this as a french guy who figured this
out is that
when the winds pick up the dust from the
sahara the mojave the sahara and
especially the great sandy desert they
blow
tear a ton of iron
across the ocean some of which falls
into the ocean to fertilize it
and of course most of it fall most of
those
most of that dust from
the sahara
feeds the amazon you know the iron in
that feeds the amazon but what's
interesting is that those iron
salts in the atmosphere have a catalytic
effect
on breaking on accelerating the
breakdown of methane
so
our process is to
spray iron chloride
into the atmosphere over the ocean to
accelerate that
the amount of that catalyst that's in
the environment it's going to have its
own chlorine as well
um and
and accelerate this natural process um
so
the nice thing about ships we're
actually going to spread it into their
uh
uh smokestack into the exhaust
plume because that's got a lot that's
that's even with all the scrubbers
that's rich in nox's and it's easy to
track as it travels around and
one of my colleagues did a calculation
he said the entire atmosphere passes
through
uh
a
ship's exhaust every six months it's
pretty nice pretty pretty good to
understand how much the atmosphere you
can get
just by
just by blowing the stuff in the um
out over the ocean
uh this pro of course this is
research right this has been this has
been uh
validated in smog chambers in by hoyt uh
and in copenhagen but uh part of our job
is to scale this up from uh from
benchtop
to the atmosphere and that's the process
that we're engaged in today
now
how do we get it out of the ocean it
turns out that there are ship these
ships that are driving around
all the time
um if you go back to that chart here
um well you can't see my finger but
you can see that ocean you can see china
on the left that ocean to uh um
that uh sorry north america to the left
the the transatlantic passage and then
on the right the chinese passage around
to to long beach uh that whole region is
uh it's hot it's got a lot of uv
um it's got a lot of methane in it um
and it's all open with open water so
we're going to be doing this in the
pelagic ocean in the
uh in international waters um there's no
topographic features you get very good
mixing
um
and
it's easy to look at with the satellite
okay
so it's interesting to look at this
catalyst when we go back to this
geoengineering question the you know
it's a catalyst it's available
everywhere it's decided you know
they make it steel plants it's used for
water treatment it's
available in bulk it's not liking we're
developing some exotic chemical um those
of you who
make circuit boards those of us who make
circuit boards in the bathtub use it as
well
um it lasts about 10 days
mainly because uh
it rains every every 10 days or so out
in that part of the ocean it's going to
wash out so it's a it's a continuous
operation system but you can turn it up
and you can turn it down depending on
how good your job you're doing or of
course
what kind of environmental issues you
want to worry about
what's interesting is you don't need to
do a lot of this a few thousand ships is
enough
to get all of the uh anthropogenic uh to
address all the anthropogenic methane
and now of course that's modeling
basically on on on our model of scale up
but it's within you know
it's a billion dollars so it's within
you know we're we're within a factor of
two or three
we think of what it what it's going to
be and that's a that's a pretty small
number in the scale in the scale of
things certainly a whole lot less than
the government is the government has uh
decided to spend on building sea walls
and rebuilding people's destroyed houses
nice thing is once you've got this
deployed
you can just tune the system
right
methane levels rise
you can switch on a few more ships if we
get a huge methane burst from the arctic
that might destroy our agriculture for
10 years
to turn on a lot of ships
it's easy we've been talking with the
ship owners and it's surprising uh just
over the past two or three years how
much pressure they're coming into to do
something about the climate they're
actually
you're sending your iphones over from
china to the u.s it causes about uh 10
of uh of carbon emissions global carbon
emissions so
they're pretty interested in being able
to help
uh i think i probably talked about why
ships um you know the pollute this is a
picture of uh the north atlantic
actually and just from the satellite you
can actually track
you can track the ships even if they
ship off even if they switch off their
transport their transponder you can
actually uh track the ships when the
atmospheric conditions are right which
is most of the time
um
so
uh
i think i've
discussed everything on this slide
except you know we're in this we're in
this where in the process scale up we're
not in deployment scale versus scale up
our plan is to start deploying late next
year
or
because things always take longer than
you think maybe the beginning of 2024
but we expect to have uh
enough ships to
to to get all the anthropogenic
methane uh within two years two years of
beginning deployment
so
we're doing pretty well on time actually
um so we're we're startup company
uh
we are uh international company you know
these days everybody's remote
uh i've got people in europe and the us
uh australia uh working on this project
uh but we're gonna i'm hiring
specifically in the bay area through the
engineering i'm looking for some uh
cam you know chemies and mechanical
engineers and some double leads for the
control systems management okay i'm
actually what i am going to do
is go to the front page where i put my
email address
and the reason is uh
i obviously
went extremely high level there's a lot
of detail that uh any nerd would want to
know so i'm happy to answer questions uh
after the fact as well uh someone wants
to do a deep dive on
you know the photochemistry or
or whatever